I want you to call your mind back to
earlier this year throughout this year
actually we'd be looking at money and
the maps to do with money okay now we've
looked at it in a couple of different
spots anything back to like the test
that you've done recently what kinds of
things in matts have we been doing that
fits under the category of finance and
money what kinds of things are we
working out ya can't astok okay so get
right up there's a big word right now by
the way just because you mentioned it
depreciation like literally yesterday my
year 11 general class we talked about
depreciation right you're like hold on
if we learnt about depreciation this
year we're going to learn about it next
year what's what's the point right well
as with everything in that's what
happens is you take ideas and then as
you progress through the years you dig
down deeper into those right so for
instance we looked at the fact there's
two different kinds of depreciation
straight line and declining balance but
you'll get on to that next year so this
whole idea that we'd be introduced to
ideas we're going to go into more depth
later that's the whole point of general
okay fantastic depreciation it's about
losing money what kinds of things how
we've got under gaining money what kinds
of topics have we looked at yep interest
fantastic and interest is kind of like
the reverse of depreciation we did under
earning money I'm sorry now to take that
back we did it under investing money
where's mine the idea being you put the
money in the bank when you buy some
shares or you do something like that and
then you get a return okay did we look
at anything else from interests
depreciation in cannot fantastic so like
you know you want to be earning some
money this is what I was referring to
before and there's lots of different
ways to earn money you can get salary
you could casually you can do it on
commission and so on and so on and so on
okay hmm probably one more major theme
that we're missing under here any
thoughts what it was yelling fantastic
very good so when you're buying things
right either they're kind of like
commodities or consumables and you want
to work out like the best price right
all their things and you've got to
borrow
money for them so again we sort of come
back to interest but instead of like
earning money you're being charged money
for the price of them for the privilege
of borrowing it from other people okay
so we've got all these ideas that we
want to cover and explore by means of
spreadsheets and not just enough to
crunch through the numbers ourselves
okay so when you have a look at this
which seems like the most natural place
to begin like this is this order is kind
of random chronologically which of these
do you think has to happen first before
any of the others very good income if
it's exactly right because you know
let's have a look at it you can't buy
anything if you don't have anyone in the
first place right I'm you can't put
money in the bank if you haven't earned
it so these sort of come after you've
earned some money right and then you
can't have depreciation something of
yours it's losing value before you've
bought something right so depreciation
probably that's going to come last so
let's think about it on their income is
what we're gonna have a look at today
hands up how many of you have a job
Jen's on yeah good all right excellent
hands down those of you've got jobs i'm
gonna draw on you for a little bit um
people who put the heads up let's just
do this really quickly on average how
many hours a week do you think you guys
work how many hours are with you 14 to
15 anyone higher than that person is
lower who reckons they work the lists
who in this room still works but yet six
hours okay where do you work I'm just
use okay fantastic so it's a pretty it's
a pretty small kind of investment in
time but we're still earning money
fortunately 15 hours rest um so where
abouts do you work awesome hey hey nice
shame in a minute it's uh I actually
really badly true story I wanted to I
wanted to work out of subway when I was
in a higher 11th yeah I do have a spare
tire I can fulfill my dream you know
anyhow my parents said their story for
nother day okay good so we've got like
this and I assume everyone else is
somewhere in between let me be ten hours
how much do I Jacob per weight roughly
that's what okay so yeah you're in
between good so here's our first piece
if you want to know how much your any
right
we need to know hours per week or even
like per shift I guess right if you want
to work out how much you're earning what
other kind of information do you need
not just time hmm not a complicated
question think about it it's like okay
I'm gonna be working for this long but I
want to know how much money I'm actually
going to receive for that how do I
calculate where now yeah I'm gonna need
to know a rape right so I need an ally
ray okay and that might be the award
wage or it might be a bit higher okay
what do you what is it for your age on
average we return no nine to ten dollars
per hour okay and you know before you
those of you who are haven't worked by
the way the half of you also have done
that we sort of like spend nine or ten
dollars we just spend it like that and
then what you start earning it you like
far out I don't spend as money anymore
took me a bit forever it's actually
better okay good that's important
there's something else here is well that
will need right because you can take
these and you can multiply by these but
as the people through what can help us
out and tell us not all ours are created
equal right Nathan is like time and a
half and there's something good so time
and a half or it might even be double
time double time to half when do you
earn more than your regular hourly rate
tom is that you asking can someone help
now like when do we earn these extra
rates appear okay public holidays right
anyone else know that suggesting every
week okay weekends that's kind of the
main categories isn't it okay and I
suppose as well Nia Nia public holidays
if they're big enough like if you're
working at a arm if you were here like
an ebay or game store something like
that and they're like yeah we're going
to do a midnight launch or there's like
some crazy boxing day sales isn't like
that it won't be a public holiday it
won't be a weekend but the hours will be
funny right yeah that's right so it's
kind of like um not just this but if
you're working strange hours like
9pm 10pm 11pm okay if you're stacking
shelves that that shift is like 8pm to
12 midnight usually for like cause of
all these that kind of thing so here we
go three pieces of information right if
we know one two three we can work out
your income yeah okay so open up Excel
if you haven't already start your
spreadsheet up and we're going to call
it a wage calculator because that's what
I'm trying to determine on the basis of
all of this right now like I said you
are more and welcome to put in your own
information on this right if you have
your own job in your hours and you know
that but if not for you're just too lazy
to think about how much did I work last
week okay you can refer this data so
let's have a look at it step by step
you've a grouse here and it's broken up
across the days of the week now this is
only got five days a week if you work on
weekends go ahead put those in that's
fine but then you'll notice there's two
rows here that both talk about hours for
each day right you got the normal ones
okay this person is working pretty
regularly except for thursdays only one
that is and then they've got another bro
for this overtime okay so that's kind of
a catch-all phrase four times where I'm
earning more than my regular rate my
every time and a half might be something
else we'll explore that in a second okay
now what I'd like you do is fill all
that in first and then we'll get to
these bits down the bottom in a minute
okay so i'll give you a little bit of
time with that on the screen to put in
that data but don't worry about rose
five six and seven don't put them in
just yet okay also while your interview
things as much as possible you might
even notice sin you've got rows and
columns there and they've actually
describe for you the ABCDE F and the
numbers for the rose and so on if you
can try to have yours really close to
what we've got it won't matter
ultimately it's just a position thing
but that way when you're reading the
formulas that I'm going to put up your
formula can be exactly the same is what
we're all doing together rather than
like off by one or down by a letter or
something like that okay so if you have
way to calculate that title right up in
the corner in cell a1
and I was here and you can see for
example you want your first number two
key in b3 if you push everything down a
little bit it won't be in b3 anymore
it'll be somewhere else it'll be fine
but your formulas will look a little bit
different to the rest of us okay